Isis Isis Isis Isis everyone's got a
reaction to Isis and for a notorious
Islamophobe Pam Geller it's to fund a
fear mongering New York subway ad
campaign insisting that moderates can
become T headers not sure if she's
convincing anyone but it's the likes of
Pam Geller that makes some Muslims feel
like they have to publicly denounce
groups like Isis and that has rekindled
a debate that's been raging for some
time do muslims have an obligation to
condemn every violent group that says it
acts in the name of Islam it all started
with hashtag not in my name a campaign
launched by young British Muslims to
remind the world that Isis doesn't
represent them or their faith it caught
on with more Muslims coming out against
Isis on social media and even in
protests on the street
Obama even gave the campaign his
presidential nod of approval during a UN
speech but wasn't nodding a bunch of
other Muslims tweeting with the hashtag
Muslim apologies they're saying stop
apologizing already cuz all that does is
implicate Muslims and put an unfair
burden on them
Epic's tweeted sorry for trigonometry
aerodynamics and astronomy and from rasz
I'm sorry my beard scares you it's
hormonal
I swear others really brought home the
point that it's downright absurd to
apologize for stuff you didn't do
I'm sorry Mufasa had to die in the Lion
King
I'm sorry Pluto's no longer a planet so
then we asked you guys if you think
Muslims should condemn Isis and the
responses we got were overwhelming yes
they do it is not fair that Muslims have
to condemn Isis yes I think Muslims and
non-muslims should condemn the actions
of Isis the Americans don't apologize
for the American government's actions no
Canadians for the Canadian government's
actions nor Jews with Israel's actions
to ask any Muslim to engage with that
group on a theological level is to
devalue and to degrade one of the
largest and frankly most peaceful
religions on earth the problem with name
calling is that extreme groups carry out
atrocities by denouncing non-believers
when mainstream Muslims do the same
they're not challenging but reinforcing
these ideologies
so do you think Muslims condemning Isis
is productive or does it just play into
the hands of people like Pam Geller let
us know want more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation available in your app store
now